Hegan Reserve was an exercise in turning an
overgrown cow paddock into a place where visitors
could rest and relax.
The natural environment would be restored,
native plants would line the stream and birds
and fish would return.
The pupils of the neighbouring schools, Southbrook
Primary and Rangiora New Life, would use it
for learning, sporting events and recreation.
Hegan Reserve is a resource that fits beautifully with our school's three kete:
knowledge, character and relationship.
We use it to develop knowledge of our environment and the social sciences,
the sciences and our P.E. activities.
It allows us the space to chill,
giving children the chance to be outside to meditate,
to be creative in their thinking.
It is a place to work for the community,
to be part of team activities
and to observe our native environment, all building relationships.
Southbrook School is proud to be part of the Hegan Reserve.
The seating was paid for by the Community Board,
as was year 13 student Joel Harnett’s sculpture
Middle Brook, which symbolises the character
of the stream as it winds its way through
the newly formed reserve.
The poem, Hegan Reserve, installed at the
entrance was written by Southbrook pupil Jasmine Chivers
and speaks of her vision for the future
of the reserve:
Kids are laughing
Dogs are barking
Sounds of joy fill the air
The creek is babbling,
scorching feet paddling
toes tickling in the soft green grass
Through the planning and efforts of pupils
at Southbrook Primary School and Rangiora
New Life School and guidance from the Council’s
Green Corps and Rangiora Community Board,
amazing progress has been made so far.
Hegan Reserve the place to be, for picnics, hammocks, friends and family.
Our board looks forward to continuing to work
with the schools and the wider community in
making Hegan Reserve an enviromental treasure
for generations to come.
We love Hegan Reserve!